a monte san martino trust was founded in
1989 and it's dedicated to the memory of
italians heroic italians and in their
honor at awards bursaries to descendants
of villagers who assisted prisoners of
war to study and we've got mild skinner
in the studio now and miles was gonna
raise some money for this trust and the
reason why he's doing it is really
really interesting and how he's doing it
there's just mind-boggling because Myles
intends to run 10 marathons and seven
dares across Italy okay that's the tough
bit your motivation is what why you do
well it's really in memory of my
grandparents so my grandmother I was
very keen and I supported this trust as
was my grandfather sadly that both now
passed away but felt there'd be a very
good and appropriate time to undertake a
huge challenge and it certainly can't be
that what was their link to Italy then
so my grandfather was captured during
the Second World War by the Germans and
imprisoned in Italy he managed to escape
from his prisoner of war camp and then
when he was hiding out in a railway
station to be deported to Germany
it was sadly bombed and a friend of his
died during that time and when he went
back after the war to England he met his
friends family know what had happened
and that's why I met my grandmother
she's Italian
no English in fact so when he went back
to England after the war and the friend
was a British prisoner of war as well
and he was treated really well by the
Italians when humanity ape from the
prison of war camp and he was in the
railway stations and has really fond
memories of his time there are not fond
memories okay grateful I suppose he
could have been worse
very much so and I think that's one of
the great things about this trust the
multi sammartino trust has been set up
to give back to the italian people who
very generously helped the British
prisoners of war escape and without
their help
my grandfather and many others probably
wouldn't have come back okay tell me
about your marathons ten in seven days
so some days you're going to be running
52 miles yeah so the average is about
3334 miles a day yeah some days would be
tougher than others but I wanted to set
myself a pretty huge here's your route
we're looking at the the route talkers
to talk us through now what we're seeing
here my photos starting in a place
called Lucca yeah and then running
through Tuscany and ending in Rome so
hoping to do in seven days in fact if
it's all possible but finishing in Rome
and hopefully a few friends and family
there and my mother and sisters and
aunts and everyone else I hope they're
going to come along and support on the
route and driving the support vehicle
which we much needed oh sure yeah and
your track record on running is what
I've every one a sub three hour marathon
and run an ultra marathon as well be
alright and if you hit any difficulty
you'll think of grandpa absolutely right
very good motivations behind it the best
thing is if you get hungry in the
evenings you're in a good country to
stock up on pizza pass - do I look ROG
miles you're gonna be doing this when at
the end of April 26th of April I starts
I set up a just giving page just giving
calm before - Skinner 2015 so any
support would be hugely appreciated good
man and keep us posted how you getting
on
and lastly thank you very much